Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we have Shiori!
Biboo!
Nerissa!
Fuwawa!
Mococo!
All of Advent, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you, Advent, for being here to celebrate with us today, the 100th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Congratulations!
We can't believe we made it to this big milestone episode today.
And Advent, thank you so much for wanting to be here today.
You are in the flesh.
I can poke you.
We will tickle her.
BAU BAU!
Maybe there's some Ruffians, some jailbirds, novelist pebbles, Adventrix joining us today for the very first time.
Wish me quick cause today's the 100th episode.
Right on!
Well, to explain a little bit, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by, usually, FUWAMOCO.
But today!
All of us!
BAU BAU!
I didn't realize it's FUWAMOCO.
Oh, that's so smart!
Wow!
Yo!
It took you 100 episodes, huh people?
Yeah, I guess it did!
I'll show you not the first time.
Christmas.
That was a Christmas episode.
So Christmas?
Yeah.
It's a rare Christmas episode.
Did you realize, Shiori?
Nerissa?
FWMC.
Now you know.
BAU BAU!
It makes sense.
That makes sense.
But!
You're here now.
Yeah.
Wow, FUWAMOCO Morning!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts, especially today, with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It's such a wonderful day!
Nerissa!
Nerissa Shiori!
There's a special rule on FUWAMOCO Morning.
You have to be loud.
Got it!
Because it's the morning!
It's the morning!
It's the boy again!
Hi!
Wow!
Well, unfortunately we have something a little bit less nice than usual.
What?
There's been another Pero Sighting.
But!
Today's the 100th episode!
It's special, you know!
Beat that guy!
Yeah!
Why does he have to do this to us?
Let's take a look then.
What?
Let's take a look at the Perroccino.
Where did you see him this time, Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
It's me!
The Great Perroccino!
Did you miss me?
That's great!
Well...
Even better than hearing those sweet words of yours, today is a big day to celebrate!
It's episode 100 of FUWAMOCO Morning, hosted by none other than the lovely girlie of FUWAMOCAR!
Have you heard of it?
Well, you know, even though they call me nasty sometimes, FUWAMOCLANS, they've been working hard.
Even though I'm off somewhere, it's not like
I don't see all the hard work they put into the show.
Constantly thinking on new topics.
Waking up at 5am back in the Northwest Passage to prepare.
Now staying up late in Japan to make sure that everything runs smoothly.
It's not the easiest show to run.
It takes a lot of dedication and planning.
So, you know, you waking up three times a week and spending this time with them,
I'm sure it means a lot.
And while I might be nasty sometimes, even under all this muscle, I have a heart of gold that appreciates those girlyos and all of you raw friends.
So please, continue to support FUWAMOCO, especially when they're working their tails off.
And celebrate this big day with them.
Because a hundred episodes isn't an easy feat.
It's nothing to sniff at!
And keep on trying to spot me, Ruffians.
It's a big game of hide and go seek between you and me, ha?
Try to find me!
Well then, congrats FUWAMOCO!
And ciao, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Cute!
That was kinda nice though.
Are you confused, Nerissa?
What?
Pero's Pero!
He's just a big nasty bomb.
Clap, clap, clap.
Pero!
Hi!
Pero cute!
He was kinda nice.
Not so nasty, like... He wasn't nasty at all today.
That's Saisou.
Exactly, Biboo!
I wasn't thinking that far.
It's okay, bro.
Let's not think that Pero was nasty.
I guess.
Yeah.
Well, I mean, it is episode 100 today.
I guess.
Maybe not so nasty today.
Not today.
Tomorrow.
BAU BAU!
I guess it wouldn't quite be FUWAMOCO Morning without Pero showing up, right?
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, we've had some really good news!
Maybe Doggy Pack, maybe some of you might have noticed a little bit earlier, but FUWAMOCO, we got some new emotes for members of the Doggy Pack!
Yes, we do!
BAU BAU BAU!
Boy, they're so cute!
You can really see them, right?
Yeah, right!
But if you open up the
The emotes, you can see them better maybe.
This time we have the illustrator Old Storm make them for us!
Thank you so much Old Storm!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
This time they're very convenient.
F-W-M-C letters!
You can use those for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Right!
You can spell things out!
I know, you can even spell M-O-C-O-C-O.
Did I spell my D wrong?
M-O-C-O-C-O.
Yeah!
Mococo!
Is it?
M-O-C-
Mococo.
M-O-C-O-C-O!
C-O-C-O-C-O!
Mocococo!
Yeah!
C-O-C-O-C-O!
You can spell things like that!
But we also have a Kusa Emoji!
And you know FUWAMO and Mococo love big emojis, you know?
So, when we do something silly, like just now, you can laugh along with us!
Yeah!
We're not bad eyes!
Yeah, we also have some PM faces, you know?
Maybe FUWAMOCO, maybe we're getting a little emotional, or needy, or crying again during a watch-along.
No, never!
Right?
And also!
Everyone's favorite!
We have Moco-chan.
Moco-chan!
Moco-chan.
Please, um, hoi Mococo.
Hoi!
Y'all, please use the words, okay?
Are you happy?
Are you happy with that?
If you're happy, that's good.
Moco-chan just goes, huh?
Huh?
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
It's Moco-chan.
Moco-chan had the best thumbs, so that's why we thought that we'd use Moco-chan's thumbs.
Yes, yes.
I heard thumbs is different.
They're the best!
Gamer thumbs!
Yes, because I really won very well in Mario Party.
Gamer!
Gamer thumbs, yes!
But, unfortunately, Ruffians, you know, we had some bad news earlier.
You know, Ruffians, it's been quite a while.
And I thought we were long past this.
We haven't really had this happening since we got to Japan that much.
But, there's been another misunderstanding.
Yeah.
A big one this time.
But, Nerissa.
It's not our misunderstanding.
It's not mine!
Fuwawa didn't do anything!
Why do you have to say Nerissa?
What's going on?
Everyone seems to think I'm colorblind.
But I'm not colorblind.
I go to the eye doctor regularly and I have to do all sorts of eye tests because I got my eye shot with a laser.
That's amazing.
I have incredible vision.
I've never had any problems at all.
I promise you I'm not colorblind.
Please stop calling me colorblind.
Thanks.
Nerissa, can you repeat that a bit louder for maybe any older Ruffians in the audience?
I'm not colorblind!
Prove it!
No, Nerissa's not colorblind!
I'm not colorblind!
She's not colorblind!
Prove it!
She has good vision.
She's the eye doctor.
I suck but I was wrong.
Yeah, I suck but I was wrong.
What color is my finger right now?
What color is your finger?
She's colorblind!
Wait, okay.
This is a misunderstanding, I'm not colorblind.
Not colorblind.
She did have lasers in her eyes, but she's not colorblind.
Yeah, Nerissa, you know you have your horns, your one and a half horns, and that's pretty cool.
But, not cool.
Lasers are pretty cool.
I love you, Nerissa!
BAU BAU!
There's no new misunderstandings, okay, Ruffians?
No new ones!
On episode 100!
You love her laser eyes?
She's not colorblind.
It's a misunderstanding.
Understood!
BAU BAU!
I am here with us!
There's a little bit of a radiant sparkling sound.
Biboo!
Good news!
You're back in Japan!
If it wasn't obvious.
Biboo you're back!
You're back in Japan!
BAU BAU!
How are you feeling?
A metal pipe fell on my head.
What?
During the bath.
During the bath!
Yeah, during the bath, I just fell on my head.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, was that the pole that you're supposed to hang your clothes up on?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that fell on my head.
But...
It just fell and then metal pipe sound effect on my head.
But Biboo, you're a strong rock, right?
I'm a strong rock, but it still hurts.
Hey Baldi, kiss my head right now.
Kiss it, kiss it.
Yay!
BAU!
Maybe Biboo needs to take another bath.
It'll buff out and you'll be shinier than before.
Biboo, now that you're back in Japan, what do you want to do?
What did you miss?
Biboo, you missed us, right?
Yeah, I wanna hang out with everybody.
That's the thing.
I wanna hang out with everybody.
Hey, no, I want you guys to take me places.
Biboo, that's what we've been saying!
You know, we owe you a date.
We're gonna take you.
There's a place that's a secret that we wanna take you.
We decided.
Yeah.
Just for Biboo, not for Shiori and the Abyssgard.
Dive and die!
That's not fair.
And actually, we talked about the long long gummies, right?
Right!
Or that you didn't get me.
Because we were gonna get you a fresh one.
And there was a good reason.
Actually, we left them out in the sun.
Yeah.
And...
They really melted.
Yeah, Nerissa's and Shiori's didn't make it to them.
Yeah.
They really melted, they were just glue.
Why?
It wasn't melted in an appetizing or photogenic way, no.
Yeah, but, you know, the plan was that, okay, we can just get fresh ones.
But... But... They sold out.
We'll fight them!
We'll switch Japan for them!
The long long gummies.
We'll buy you one then!
Don't you want to tie your gummies all together and make a big giant advent circle gummies?
That sounds like fun!
What?
We'll find a way to find it done!
But we'll come back to Japan, Biboo!
We're happy!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
We just want to say, you know, today is FUWAMOCO Morning's 100th episode.
And just thank you so so much for always letting us share your mornings with you.
You know, it's been really fun!
We've had some really silly moments!
Yeah!
But, maybe some things said that they shouldn't have been said!
But, you know, it's also been a bit of a rough journey sometimes.
You know, back in the Northwest Passage, FUWAMOCO- Like Pero mentioned, we wake up at 5am to prepare things, and some days, you know, on the really special FUWAMOCO Mornings,
Sometimes we didn't really even... We didn't sleep at all.
It was just a FUWAMOCO continuation for us.
Yeah.
But, you know... You know, there's been some times that the Barker is just not really working.
You know, maybe we feel a little less fluffy and fuzzy.
But you know, at the end of every morning, we're always so happy that you were there and that we were able to do it.
You know, it started to feel like, Ruffians, you're the one starting off our day on the right.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
I don't know, Advent, do you remember?
Episode 50 of FUWAMOCO Morning!
It was really tough for us.
Right.
What should we do, Advent?
Should we continue FUWAMOCO Morning?
And we talk to you, and then we're like, okay!
Okay, we're gonna do that!
We're gonna continue.
And then FUWAMOCO flip-flop.
Thank you.
Thank you for always being here to support us and listen to us.
FUWAMOCO's being especially silly and getting ourselves into trouble and mischief.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Wow, we thought you know.
It's the 100th episode.
A lot of special mornings spent together.
And Ruffians!
We asked you for your favorite moments.
If you could share those with us.
Thank you!
So today we gathered some of them.
We want to take a little look back at them.
Shall we?
BAU BAU!
Hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Today!
It's a good question.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
Some of Pero's medical records.
We love cats!
Yes!
Ruffians, do you know much about this place?
You asked if they can live in Moco-chan's bellybutton?
De-den!
I mean, howl, howl, BAU BAU!
There's someone very, very, very important and dear to us.
Pero's stuck in this dog's tummy?
That's not us, but it is us.
Moco-chan, thank you for the drawing.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
It's very good.
No, don't give me the tissue!
No tissue!
Ouchie!
What's the reasoning why it's used, Moco-chan?
Because cat starts with a C. And V starts with a D. This is how she looks all the time.
Right!
Are you using your brain?
You did it!
I did it!
Ruffians, will you forgive me?
Will you forgive her, dude?
Ruffians, would you like me to be your accountant?
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
You wanna do this, right?
You wanna do this!
I wanna do this!
Okay! 3, 2, 1!
I wanna do it!
Don't stop!
Don't!
Take care of me!
Extreme violence!
It's just violence!
It's just that, Moco-chan!
I believe you'll be all okay!
Let's do it together, okay?
Stay strong!
Business as usual.
Ruffians keep on muttering strange things like, business as usual.
Even if sometimes no one else notices it!
What's important is that you recognize all your hard work.
Moco-chan's chair is REVISED!
Yeah!
Rocking tea!
New e-rolls!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
It was planned to be every single day of the work week.
Second cover song is... De-den!
Cute na Kanoja!
BAU BAU!
I know you can do it.
Let's try to groom from every mistake and not let them take us down.
It was a nice afternoon, and then suddenly, from right in front of us and out of nowhere, a grizzly bear started running towards us like a bull, so we're like... No!
Water!
Kept on touching the monitor multiple, multiple times repeatedly.
This weekend, there's definitely one place you'll be able to find us, and that place is... New York City!
BAU BAU!
It's me, Pero.
As you can see, Ruffians, I'm on my vacation.
You've decided to erase Nerissa's name and put yours on it?
Huh?
What are you doing?
Blubbers!
You remember, right?
Right!
One level in particular is very strong at counting, has been counting every time we say BAU BAU since our debut.
We reached our goal of a certain amount of Ruffians subscribed to our channel.
Mama Puppy will leak our guest appearance!
We hit 300,000 followers on Twitter!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
FUWAMOCO Scoop!
Yeah, for anything, you know, you see something interesting or silly going on, we want to know about it!
You want to know, let us know!
I'm Perroccino!
And I'm strong!
Yeah!
You better not doubt it or I'll rough you up!
I did it!
It was all over my lips, but I really did not like that!
We'll have to have a toad off later.
Toad off!
Oh yeah!
There was a very cute Moco-chan cosplay spotted on TV in the Philippines too!
Come on, don't make a pain face.
Don't worry, don't sweat the small stuff.
And you know what?
You'll be okay.
Yikes.
I really didn't realize that you're that kind of dog, Moco-chan.
I was just trying to be a good imposter.
New outfit!
BAU BAU!
Good morning, money puppies!
I was.
I wasn't.
That sounded suspicious.
I kept on hearing Nerissa laughing.
I wake up to her laughing.
Look at that.
Yeah.
She's trying to steal it.
BAU BAU.
Pushing yourself hard to do something that you don't want to do isn't always the right answer.
You have to think of the importance of the journey, not just the destination, okay?
There was some intense discussion about... ...my fuzziness.
That's you, Ruffian!
It's you!
It
Moco-chan's almost at a total of 200 on-stream sneezes!
The other night, I had a dream about our mamas!
Both Mama Puppy and Icomochi-mama!
Even though not many people might recognize their efforts.
I know that in your heart, you're doing it.
And I do too, okay?
Together with Ino-senpai!
Senpai!
Ino-senpai!
It's been five months since the Doggy Pack formed and our membership opened!
But if it falls onto me, I will be in my grave earlier than...
Your mom loves you very much.
Mama puppy can bark quickly with some hungry kicks.
BAU BAU!
What do you think, Ruffians?
If FUWAMOCO is your oshi, then actually you have three oshi.
Fuwawa, Mococo, and FUWAMOCO!
I'm a proper demon dog, okay?
Don't misunderstand.
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Oh my goodness.
Marine-senchou-senpai!
Do us an illustration!
Just for us!
Just for us, okay?
Make sure today you let those that matter to you know that they matter.
Marshmallow mania.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's hard to tell what exactly it is.
Thank you for always being here to have so much fun with us, Ruffians.
You're resilient, so don't be scared of things and challenge yourself.
And even if maybe things don't go exactly as you imagined, you'll end somewhere new and filled with possibilities.
The past month or so, we've actually been in Japan moving into our new dog house!
She was so cute and fluffy looking!
She was so cute and she just popped out from the corner of the door frame and was like, FUWAMOCO-CHAN!
If you click on it on FUWAMOCO there, you can hear many different BAU BAUs.
We want to share a special FUWAMOCOland with you at the end of each stream.
hololive onee-chan, she's made an unexpected new friend!
Funny and ugly.
And that's why his name is the FUG one.
Mayo Chuchu.
Chuchu giving kisses to the mayonnaise too.
You got MVP too, right?
I did!
A different kind of MVP though.
I got...
Most Captured!
I believe in you!
So do your best, okay?
I'm cheering for you!
Huh?
Why did you poke me?
What are you doing?
Us, FUWAMOCO, we have an official rival.
Kevin Lamar.
That's Fubuzu and I guess
The Great Perroccino.
We've been on ad checks going around Taipei!
You can hear us BAU BAUing from the streets, Ruffians!
Over 850,000 YouTube subscribers!
850,000 Ruffians, right!
BAU BAU!
Such a big milestone!
Please have fun!
Yeah, for the first time in person!
Oh my goodness, she was so excited!
She picked me up into a big hug and spun me around and around and around and then she covered me with so much strength into a wall!
There's so many places with such a long list of things we want to do together with our
BAU BAU!
Thank you for 100 episodes of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
100 episodes over!
Good morning!
BAU BAU!
Hopefully, very, very many more, as long as you let us spend your morning with you!
BAU!
But!
Right now, we get to spend a bunch of time together with Advent!
A-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-
And you know, there's already been so many exciting things that's been announced, right?
One, FUWAMOCO's 3D debut this summer!
You know Breaking Dimensions, New York City?
Today is, as you know, our first anniversary.
It's only in a month and a bit.
Right.
What?
Really?
Yeah!
Only a month and a bit, people!
Right!
We had so many exciting things.
Yeah.
And also what's really exciting is that we're all here in this room today together!
Yay!
Thank you.
Yeah.
That's not the only time we'll be in the same room together this week, right?
Right.
Yeah, maybe.
Because, well, there's a good reason.
No, no, no!
No, Shiori, don't!
We'll be having two advent collabs on the weekend!
You know, we've been doing all the collabs together pretty much weekly, right?
Right, since we debuted!
And usually we have our set time, but this time it's a little different.
It's two hours later than our usual time.
So pay attention!
And I feel like, you know, there's been so much excitement!
Sometimes you can be like, I can't handle all this excitement!
I need to take a break!
Are you tired of the excitement, Adventrix?
No way!
If you kinda feel like that, are you sleepy now?
You don't want excitement?
No!
You can't miss this, okay?
You'll have to be here for sure, okay?
We still haven't really quite decided things, right?
No.
But it's gonna be a fun time for sure, okay?
Two days in a row!
Two days!
So please, I know it's not far off, but make sure you mark it in your schedule for this week, okay?
Okay!
Yeah.
Got it.
Thumbs up, you understand.
Understood.
No misunderstandings.
Yeah!
Good, good.
Your thumbs work well for putting things in the schedule.
BAU BAU!
We're excited to see you there!
Wow!
It's the 100th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning that just happens to be at the beginning of the week!
And you know the start of a new week means that it's the perfect time to challenge yourself to something new, right Moco-chan?
You know this very well, right?
Yeah, that's because almost every new week since FUWAMOCO Morning started, Moco-chan's been challenging herself
To overcome something she dislikes.
Which is natto!
And, Moco-chan, how has it been going?
Especially recently, huh?
It's been good.
Ruffians, has it been good?
I've been doing well.
Lots of progress.
Just today, you know, it's a very special 100th episode.
Advent, you know, you're here together with us.
I thought you know.
If maybe... Don't finish that sentence.
All of you guys just want to have some natto together.
Maybe Moco-chan, you can graduate from the natto challenge.
It's better if we do it together, right?
Right?
Friendship.
Friends together doing something.
Overcoming something.
Maybe difficult.
Can I go back to jail?
No!
No jail.
You can't escape the natto.
They can be jailed.
They can be jailed in natto.
I am not Nobita-chan!
Nobita-chan!
Nobita-chan
That's what Moco-chan says every time!
It doesn't work, Nerissa!
It doesn't work!
What if I say I'll pad it better after?
That won't save me from having it come back.
Okay, well, first, Shiori, Biboo, Nerissa, Moco-chan.
First, let's say thank you to the farmers in Canada and the United States of America who worked hard to make this natural.
It's from Canada and the United States of America.
The beans are from there, I think.
Yeah.
I don't know what they made in that, though.
No!
Okay, Advent!
Advent!
Itadakimasu!
No!
Itadakimasen!
Itadakimasu!
Okay, Shiori said it the loudest, so pass it over to Shiori!
Shiori, please.
Please don't drop it.
Oh, oh, oh, she has... How many beads is that?
Shiori!
Don't fake it!
Don't fake it, Shiori!
Why?
Don't drop it!
No!
Oh, you loved it?
Oh, if you loved it, then Nerissa will love it because Nerissa loves Shiori too!
It's stinky.
It is.
Hi!
That's what Moco-chan says every morning.
Really?
The both of you?
Oh my, Biboo!
Biboo!
Help!
That's a lot of Biboo!
Biboo you need to do it!
We don't have tissue.
Biboo!
Biboo did well.
I'll take it.
Biboo drink the water.
Biboo is drunk for every 200.
Biboo's a gamer when it comes to real life too though.
That was like 10 beans just now.
Do you have candy?
I have a cough drop!
It saves me so much!
Wow!
I'm so proud of Biboo!
More proud than I've ever been of Moco-chan ever!
Biboo strong!
Yeah!
Okay, Moco-chan!
I won't let everyone beat me at Mario Party and then... Biboo at the natto challenge?
Why do they smell so strong?
Moco-chan!
That's one bean you gotta hurry up!
That's a bad thing!
That's Shiori and Nerissa, okay?
It can't be!
Biboo just took a mouthful of it!
She didn't eat her!
Nobody said!
I'm just not hoping I'm natto by myself already.
You did today, though.
I don't have a stomach either.
I see the tummy right there, though.
Okay, Moco-chan.
Mococo is in danger.
Yes!
Okay! 3, 2, 1!
It's on the tongue?
It's a- Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Yeah, you're right!
Right, there was a lot of Ruffians.
I did it.
Okay, then you can do the rest, Moco-chan.
What?!
Okay, one... There's a string to my lip!
I can see it, it's shiny.
Just take a big ol' scoop.
Yeah, a big ol' scoop just like Biboo did.
I just scooped it.
Do you want me to do the same?
I can do the same.
I can feed you, Moco-chan.
I can feed you.
Do you want me to feed you, baby Moco-chan?
I'm done.
I'm done with this.
I have one bean.
Well, you know what the conclusion is then, Moco-chan.
Shiori, how could you say that?
How could you say that?
How could you say
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
There is like a natto that's more small, like a chopped up natto.
Apparently that's easier to eat, but Moco-chan really refuses that one too, so... Wow, Moco-chan!
I didn't eat it all together with Advent, so... I did well, though.
Ruffians!
I did the best, right?
Did you?
I did the best!
Biboo did the best!
She didn't complain, she didn't scream, she didn't go... Like you used to do, Biboo was just like... She said weh a lot.
Yeah, not like you said.
Weh.
Congratulations, Bau Bau-chan!
Well, I think you're still gonna have to try your best.
Ruffians!
You know, you saw Albert do the best of this challenge.
Does it make you feel like you want to challenge something new?
Maybe something you're scared of?
Make sure you're like Shiori!
You do your best, you don't go... You can't let your best go to waste!
It's a new week!
Do your best!
BAU BAU!
De-den!
Why aren't you sharing your doggies with us?
Yo!
I was gonna say, does this mean... It's your dogs!
Excuse me.
Demon dogs, okay?
Yeah!
All of us!
We are demon guide dogs!
We protect your smile!
I think you are Ruffians.
Without you, okay?
Don't get it mistaken.
BAU BAU!
Advent, how do we BAU BAU?
How does FUWAMOCO BAU BAU?
BAU BAU!
That's pretty good, Biboo, but Nerissa, did you try your best?
Oh, that was better.
Shiori!
What?
Okay, maybe that's Fuwawa with the voice changer.
What would you rate us?
10 out of 10.
11 out of 10.
20 out of 10.
100 out of 10.
BAU BAU out of 10.
Numbers don't mean anything.
Like, fluffy and fuzzy, like you'd pat us every day of the day.
The fluffiest.
Mococo.
I already knew that.
Ruffians, what about you?
10,000 out of 10!
BAU BAU!
Okay, well, this is embarrassing, so... Today I went on a walk!
Ruffians, we've been going for walks for hours, touching the paws.
Let's see... De-den!
You can't really see it that well, huh?
An adventure in the city this time, maybe?
Oh, you found some graffiti that reminds me of Moco-chan!
It says... No.
No.
No!
Moco-chan doesn't say no like that!
No, I don't say it like that.
I say it... No way!
No way to say it like that!
No way to say it!
No!
That sounds annoying.
Moco-chan.
Moco-chan's not annoying.
I'm not annoying.
You're not annoying yo.
Mococo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not annoying, I'm Mococo!
Exactly.
That's annoying.
BAU BAU!
Well, let's see what we have for the Question of the Day today.
For the Question of the Day, we have...
De-den!
Finally! 100!
I know you both have asked what our favorite moments from FUWAMOCO Morning are, but do you two have any episodes or preparations for them that were super memorable?
Any other big plans for the show beyond 100?
I know a lot of our favorite moments, Ruffians, were your favorite moments too.
Makes sense.
It makes sense.
But one of mine, I think Nerissa, do you remember your apology corner?
Misunderstanding?
Misunderstanding, I know.
I think I had the most out of unacknowledging you guys.
Yeah... Yeah, that's not a good... But you know... Shiori, Biboo, have you had any misunderstandings you haven't told us about?
Or did you solve them without FUWAMOCO Morning?
I guess that's helpful.
Yeah...
That's probably for the best.
Yeah.
And then, I guess, other memorable moments!
You know, the FUWAMOCO Mornings that we worked all through the night for, you know.
The ones we were really worried about.
Yeah.
The ones where we were like... Before, you know, we were gonna... Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
Especially the pilot right after it debuted, you know.
Been talking to Mama Puppy right after it because it's so busy!
And we're finally going to sleep and like, we debuted!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
I mean, just like, all the, you know, there's the good times and there's also like the rough times, you know, where maybe we doubted ourselves.
But we're really worried about a lot of stuff.
But now, this one!
This is one of our favorite FUWAMOCO Mornings.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
We love you too!
Well, Ruffians, we just wanna say thank you so much for always being here and sharing bits of yourselves with us every single FUWAMOCO Morning!
You know, we hope that you'll continue to open up yourself lots to us.
Spend your mornings with us.
Send us your Pero Sightings.
Let us into your lives a bit, okay?
Any photos of the funny things you notice on your daily walks.
Maybe any questions you can think up for us.
And of course, your doggy of the days.
We want to know which doggy is of your day.
You want to see Pero more?
It's episode 100, Ruffians.
We're always waiting for your tweets, Ruffians!
You know where!
At... Hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream, we have... De-den!
We're gonna be playing Jump Box Games together with Calli-senpai and hololive!
BAU BAU will be over on Calli-senpai's channel!
Who knows who's gonna participate?
FUWAMOCO will be there!
Biboo!
Hi!
I'll be there.
You'll be there?
We'll see though.
Yeah, we're gonna have some silly times.
It'll be at 7am PT.
Kind of like a bit of an early FUWAMOCO Morning, but with more senpai and some Jackbox games.
We hope you'll join us there.
It'll be really silly.
I'm not sure what to expect.
Double the trouble that you love.
Exactly.
And then, for our Ruffians who are joining us through the archive today, here is your FUWAMOCO word!
It's... BAU BAU 100 Mornings!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for waking up early, for pulling yourself out of your bed, and allowing us, FUWAMOCO and Advent today, to be part of your morning routine for 100 episodes!
We feel so thankful for every morning that we get to spend with you.
Really, really.
Thank you, Ruffians.
Thank you!
Well, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Serene Caffeine!
BAU BAU!
Nick!
Charetto.
BAU BAU!
The name I get.
Ritsu Abyssgard.
BAU BAU!
Nanoi.
Cool Dog.
BAU BAU!
Fantastic.
Mikami.
BAU BAU!
French Fancy.
Dog Salmon.
BAU BAU!
Leafy.
BAU BAU BAU!
Zippo.
After Vlog.
BAU BAU!
Hedgy.
Omazuyo.
BAU BAU!
Cybersyn.
Mr. Fujisawa.
BAU BAU!
Black Santana.
Lloyd in a Box.
BAU BAU!
Pinkie.
Wee-chan.
BAU BAU!
Clown-o-phoenix and Fancy.
Apple Cyrus.
BAU BAU!
Potato.
Ryuma.
BAU BAU!
Sarah Irwin.
Cottonball Lightning.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!